welcome back everybody to the David
packman show Luke Beasley here filling
in for David while he is away we have a
wild show ahead of us so stick around
let's dive in ladies and gentlemen I
have for you the true Twitter files what
should be the actual conversation going
on around Twitter social media platforms
and their role in our political process
specifically the 2020 election now
before we dive into these fascinating
details what am I connecting this to
well of course shortly after Elon Musk
became the head of Twitter he started
promoting and facilitating the Twitter
files and these were supposed to reveal
through the analysis of behind the
scenes records at Twitter the way that
Twitter went after Trump treated him so
poorly treated the conservative movement
so poorly and unfairly and made the
difference in the 2020 election well as
David has done and I've done on a
respective of shows when you actually
walk through the details of the Twitter
files that is not shown it's a pretty
dishonest narrative because when you
dive into it you realize these claims
are not being backed up in the way that
they should and this does not show what
people are saying that it shows right
and so within that context I want to
dive into now
a much more profound and fascinating
part of this in my mind which is
through the January 6 select committee's
investigation a part of it that was
previously unseen up until now reveals
that actually the exact opposite was
going on Twitter and other social media
platforms were giving preferential
treatment to Trump two far-right
extremists out of fear of backlash and
so the opposite was going on then the
narrative that we've heard from right
Wingers as of late this is truly
interesting stuff they decided not to
include it in their final report
because a number of reasons my take on
it was you kind of can only get the
public to focus on a few things you
can't give them a million things focus
on with this type of story and the
extensive nature of the report was
already going to be
quite the batch of information to go
through to talk about and to open up a
whole another can of worms with its
whole another group of contra
adversities and all of that they didn't
see us worth it and so it wasn't
including the final report but they did
a lot of Investigations a lot of
interviews in regard to this exact issue
the Washington Post has a story on it
what the January 6 Pro found out about
social media but didn't report
the January 6 committee spent months
Gathering stunning new details on how
social media companies failed to address
the online extremism and calls for
violence that preceded the capital Riot
the evidence they collected was written
up in a 122 Patron page memo that was
circulated among the committee according
to a draft viewed by The Washington Post
but in the end committee leaders
declined to delve into those Topics in
detail in their final report reluctant
to dig into the roots of domestic
extremism taking hold in the Republican
Party Beyond former president Donald
Trump and concerned about the risks of a
public battle with powerful tech
companies
Congressional investigators found
evidence that Tech platforms especially
Twitter failed to heed the own uh their
own employees warnings about violent
rhetoric on their platforms and bent
their rules to avoid penalizing
conservatives particularly then
president Trump out of fear of reprisals
the draft report details how most
platforms did not take dramatic steps to
rein in extremist content until after
the attack on the capital despite clear
red flags across the internet so
bending their own rules to allow Trump
to continue violating their rules
without
being held accountable now we'll skip
over a part of this just for the sake of
time that walks through the specifics of
why they decided not to include it
in their final report but we'll pick up
here titled did Twitter give Trump a
pass some of what investigators
uncovered in their interviews with
employees of the platforms contradicts
Republican claims that the tech
companies displayed a liberal bias in
their moderation decisions contradicts
that an allegation that has gained new
attention recently as musk has promoted
a series of leaked internal
Communications known as the Twitter
files the transcripts indicate the
reverse with former Twitter employees
describing how the company gave Trump
special treatment Twitter employees they
testified could not even view the former
president's Tweets in one of their key
content moderation tools and they
ultimately had to create a Google
Document to keep track of his tweets as
calls grew to suspend his account quote
Twitter was terrified of the backlash
they would get if they followed their
own rules and applied them to Donald
Trump said one former
employee
so this highlights a few things the
takeaways I think should be number one
this flies in the face of this
contradicts disproves The Narrative
we've heard from the right wing that
there was this big
conspiracy against Trump and
conservatives in the build up to the
2020 election trying to take them down
if that was the case they would not have
been doing so much breaking their back
to prevent their own employees
from moderating Trump's content from
holding him accountable with the rules
they've already had laid out number two
takeaway
this is absolutely a part of what led to
January 6th what caused January 6. the
ability for this far-right extremism to
fester for these lies to spread and so
everyone has different takes on how we
address that and that's an interesting
conversation but we can just recognize
reality and say a big role in all of
this in the January 6 attack in the lies
and the speed in which they were able to
spread is the fact that Twitter and
other social media platforms
um
absolutely did not apply their own rules
their own standards to these individuals
the same way they would to somebody else
and then the third is going forward
let's take this as a lesson and let's
figure out what are we going to do going
forward and so social media platforms us
just as a country and the kind of public
discourse need to sort out it's going to
be tough because
we're also having these conversations
with individuals that we're talking
about being the problem right
um but figuring out how we move forward
and not allow this level of Deceit this
level of dishonesty and then the
reaction to that by the platforms being
to um
assist not necessarily intentionally but
assist in that through their fear of
backlash and their lack of enforcing
their own rules
we need to figure out how to handle that
going forward for sure make sure that
you are subscribed to the David Pacman
show channel what you're watching if
you're watching on YouTube right now and
I have a show of my own uh when I'm not
hosting this show I'm hosting the Luke
Beasley show and you can find that at
Luke Beasley b-e-a-s-l-e-y on YouTube
hit that subscribe button
speaking of trump and Twitter and social
media it turns out Trump is actually
wanting to get back on Facebook and
start tweeting on Twitter of course his
cap his account has been brought back on
Twitter but uh he has not tweeted yet
and he's also lobbying to get back on
Facebook hear from NBC News mounting a
comeback for the White House Donald
Trump is looking to regain control
over as powerful social media accounts
with access to his Twitter account back
Trump's campaign is formerly petitioning
Facebook's parent company to unblock his
account thereafter it was locked in
response to the U.S Capitol Riot two
years ago quote Trump is probably coming
back to Twitter it's just a question of
how and when Senate Republican who spoke
on a condition of anonymity to discuss
private conversations with Trump about
returning to the platform quote he's
been talking about it for weeks but
Trump speaks for Trump so it's anyone's
guess what he'll do or say or win
another Trump Confidant who also didn't
want to be identified speaking about
conversations with him said that Trump
has sought input for weeks about hopping
back on Twitter and that his campaign
advisors have also workshopped ideas
for his first tweet and then Facebook
has not given a direct answer yet but it
seems likely that they might let him
back on and so he shortly could be
active on Twitter and Facebook once
again here's a bit of this being
discussed
um on CNN former president Donald
Trump's campaign petitioning Facebook to
unblock his account that of course
remember the social media giant locked
it in response to the January 6th riot
at the Capitol let's bring in Sienna's
Kristen home she's following this story
for us Kristen tell us more so John as
we know Facebook's ban was not
indefinite and as we reported last week
The Meta the parent group was already
having meetings deliberating whether or
not they were going to let former
president Trump back on its site in fact
they were taking it so seriously they
had a small working group within the
company that was working on that but now
it appears that the campaign is trying
to accelerate that process they sent a
letter to Metta asking for Trump to be
reinstated and to have a meeting with
that parent company now I want to read
you one expert excerpt of why they say
they think that they should be
reinstated it says Donald J Trump is a
declared candidate for president of the
United States we believe the ban on
President Trump's account on Facebook
has dramatically distorted and inhibited
the public discourse moreover every day
that President Trump's political voice
remains silenced furthers an
inappropriate interference in the
American political and election process
so why does this matter well if you kept
up with politics pre and post Trump's
social media bands you remember the
significant nature of how that affected
his ability to use his megaphone use his
voice to craft and influence the public
discourse the daily conversations and
yeah now he's on true social and he
occasionally says stuff or he's
constantly saying stuff we occasionally
cover it but it's not the same as when
he had his voices on Twitter and
Facebook but Twitter most significantly
and so whether or not he starts tweeting
again
whether or not Facebook allows them back
on will actually affect the next two
years and the voice that he has in his
presidential campaign and uh how he's
able to leverage that in different ways
in a very significant way and so it's
fascinating to watch it's weird and
strange to try to understand why now it
makes sense if
the past actions they got banned for
didn't change why now it makes sense to
bring them back who knows but it seems
likely that will indeed occur and we
will continue to keep up with it follow
me on Twitter Luke P Beasley
lying Republican Congressman George
Santos has told so many lies
genuinely and I'm not saying this just
as kind of a phrase I mean genuinely
it's hard to keep up with all the lies
that he's told
well one of the lies he told was that
his mom died in 9 11. and we already
knew this was a lie or at least he was
lying about one of the claims he had
made about this topic because he said
his mom died 9 11. he said both of his
parents survived 9 11 and he said that
his mom in 2021 died five years in the
past which would not be 2001. so
something had to be off there
um and now we understand it has been
confirmed based on immigration records
that indeed he was like so let me remind
you about this first and then we'll take
a look at the new reporting here's him
saying both of his parents were down
there on 9 11 and survived and I can't
believe that that's the reality that
we're living in that I have to hear
somebody actually say that the 911
memorial canceled the same Memorial
where many New Yorkers long Islanders on
even New Jersey and Connecticut
residents perished
um First Responders uh law enforcement
everybody you know people working to
tell hours and media people everybody
just perished and and to to
I get emotional my parents were both
down there uh the day of the attacks and
uh fortunately none of them passed um
but to see that the families of those
who lost their loved ones will will be
recused from having okay
so you see that there and then
also which is a very contradictory he
said that
um his mother died on 9 11 as you'll see
a tweet up on the screen here 911
claimed my mother's life claimed my
mother's life but then in a different
tweet he said December 23rd and this is
in 2021 this year marks five years I
lost my best friend and Mentor mom you
will live forever in my heart so again I
say all those things can't be true
simultaneously both of his parents can't
survive 9 11. his mom died at 9 11 and
his mom died five years before 2021
really doesn't make sense and now we
know for sure that he was lying here
from The New York Times
representative George Santos of New York
has said consistently that his mother uh
Fatima devolder was working at her
office in the South Tower of the World
Trade Center during the September 11
2001 attacks even as he altered His
official biography to remove other false
claims Mr Santos account of ties to the
tragedy he remained but official
immigration documents reviewed by the
New York Times on Wednesday directly
contradict that claim too an application
for a visa to enter the United States
filed in 2003 Ms devolder said that she
had left the country for Brazil in June
1999 and had not returned since an
earlier paperwork filed in June 2001
three months before the attacks Mr
volder said that she had been unable to
return to the United States since 1999
because her Green Card had been stolen
in Brazil so now we have confirmation he
was definitely definitely lying
absolutely and each one of these
Revelations is stunning to me because I
just can't comprehend it and I was
explaining on my show kind of asking
myself the question for the audience why
do I keep talking about this we get it
he's a liar why is every single
Revelation have to be discussed and to
me it comes down to Fascination and
accountability
I am fascinated with a human person a
human being who lives in the same world
I live in being able to be this
dishonest this deceitful this vile
and his dishonesty goes beyond just
normal dishonesty that we see in
politics he picks the worst things to be
his honest about pulling from drawing
from the trauma and the devastation of
people
saying that he lost employees in the
Pulse Nightclub shooting saying that he
had a Holocaust survivors in his family
saying that he had his mom either
survive or die in 9 11 and all of those
things weren't true that is so horrible
and so it's fascinating because I can't
understand it and it's wild and then
also if we are going to hold him
accountable or I should say if he's
going to be held accountable which it
doesn't look like he will be it's going
to be because this stays in the public
conversation and it's unfortunate
because it looks like the only chance
for accountability is going to come
either with his legal troubles or with
uh his if he tries to run for reelection
in two years the Republican party is
standing behind him and that tells you a
lot about the modern Republican party
but all in all just really wild stuff
make sure you're subscribed to the David
Pacman show the YouTube channel but then
also if you like what you're seeing here
as I'm guest hosting for David today
follow my YouTube channel subscribe to
it Luke Beasley on YouTube quick break
we'll be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
welcome back to the show Luke Beasley
filling in for David while he is away if
you want to check me out you like what
you see Luke Beasley on YouTube the link
should be in the description if you're
watching on YouTube radical republican
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green
appeared on Fox news with Sean Hannity
kind of continuing in her tour of trying
to make herself more mainstream let's
forget all the past Bonkers conspiracy
theorists things I've said and make me a
serious congresswoman and conservative
media is assisting in that and the
Republican party is assisting in that
well
especially the third clip I'm going to
show you out of this interview really
highlights how little both Sean Hannity
and Marjorie green understand about what
they're talking about and it's honestly
really embarrassing for these two
individuals but before we do that the
first two clips relate to
the removing of certain Democratic
Congress people from committees so I'll
show you these and then we'll get to the
really Bonkers clip
no not at all and you can see there's a
major difference in the leadership with
Kevin McCarthy as Speaker of the House
and Nancy Pelosi is Speaker of the House
Nancy Pelosi and the Democrats removed
me from committees from things they
didn't like on my Facebook years before
I became a member of Congress but you
can see that Kevin McCarthy isn't being
political he's removing members of
Congress that need to be removed it's a
so she's correct that
Nancy Pelosi and Kevin McCarthy are very
different in the type of speaker they're
going to be but not in the way uh that
she would believe necessarily and
I'll show you the next clip actually and
then we'll discuss about this
committee's issue is Kevin McCarthy a
speaker of the house is doing the right
thing and removing these Democrat
members that deserve to be removed ilhan
Omar is another example she's
anti-semitic and she should not be on
Foreign Affairs these aren't political
things these are the right things to do
so
from the Jewish space lasers believing
person she's saying that Ilan Omar is
anti-Semitic and that's why she
shouldn't be on committees
but to the point of
Kev McCarthy is not doing these actions
for political purposes but instead for
good reason is completely silly because
I don't think there's any better reason
to remove someone from committees than
the reasons Democrats did Paul gosar
posting that animation of AOC getting
killed and then Marjorie Greene and all
for conspiracy theories the Jewish space
lasers and all of that those are good
reasons that someone probably shouldn't
be serving on committees it's absolutely
a hundred percent political that Kevin
McCarthy is taking people off of
committees that are perfectly qualified
to serve those positions but are
Democrats and uh that's the real reason
okay so third clip watch them discuss
and watch how Sean Hannity sets up the
conversation around the debt ceiling and
How Deeply confused he gets and then
Marjorie green just goes along with the
confusion let me ask you
um I know the Democrats desperately want
to distract from the the issue of of the
president and the classified top secret
documents now in four locations I get
that so they're trying to Gin up the
American people on the issue of the debt
ceiling my understanding is that really
won't be be an issue for a number of
months but when it is an issue what will
Republicans do will they be United what
are the things that they will demand
in exchange for going along with the
debt ceiling because the hyperbole I'm
sure will be out of control of Full
Faith and and gov of the United States
government is on the line and credit of
the government is on the line uh you're
going to shut down the government and
meanwhile people will still get their
Social Security checks their Medicare
the military will be up and running and
most people get a furlough and they get
paid when they get back to work so all
that hyperbole is coming but what will
the Republicans want and will they stay
together
okay so we will let Marjorie green
answer but first let's just kind of
break down what was so confused about
that setup to the question what did he
do there he merged the concepts of
funding the government and raising the
debt ceiling now these things will
coincide and the negotiations might get
intertwined and be going on at similar
times and but the the funding of the
government and the government shutdowns
that are threatened is different than
the raising of the debt ceiling and us
falling through on our financial
obligations so he's correct that
whenever we get in the negotiations
about funding the government if they
don't come to an agreement within the
government and the government shuts down
the necessary functions of the
government still move forward but if it
goes on long enough negative
consequences absolutely occur but then
he shifted and kind of blended into the
Full Faith and Credit in the United
States and the fact that we would be in
a bad economic situation and we would be
losing worldwide credibility if we
didn't raise a debt ceiling and follow
through on our financial obligations and
blending those two things in his setup
to make it seem like it's not a big deal
and they're gonna fear Monger so
whenever you hear it don't take it
seriously but we should take seriously
both of those things but not right in
the debt ceiling could be disastrous and
it's not the time to argue overspending
if you don't want the government to
spend as much you have to push for that
when you're deciding on spending that
makes a whole lot of sense which would
be when you're passing bills when you're
debating over the funding of different
programs but when you talk about raising
the debt ceiling that's just following
through on financial obligation spending
that's already been committed to
and we must do that to stay credible
as
um a government with that and all of
those things and so he's completely
discombobulated setting up that question
but here's her answer
well I think this is an important issue
to talk about Sean thank you for
bringing it up but we also want to point
out that Nancy Pelosi Chuck Schumer Joe
Biden Mitch McConnell all of who have
served if you add up the years they've
been in Congress or are in power in
Washington we're looking at 150 years of
four people's combined uh time in
Washington so they know what they're
doing when they kick the can down the
road giving the debt ceiling issue to
the Republican majority which we started
here in January it's an important issue
for our conference to come together on
because as you said the government will
keep on running yes people's social and
again she's merging the concepts but we
will skip forward to a pretty notable
part here at the end you have to have I
for one will not sign a clean uh Bill
raising the debt the debt limit
so she won't
buy into a clean bill raising the debt
ceiling
there it is and I've talked about
extensively now on my show that this is
the Republican nonsense we saw
foreshadowed with the Kev McCarthy
speakership debacle and we're going to
be experiencing this I know David has
also talked a ton about this we will be
experiencing this for the next two years
and it will be disaster after disaster
and debacle after debacle Carrie lake is
still
doing her thing still lying as much as
possible and specifically of course
about the election that occurred in
Arizona where she lost as much as she
doesn't want to believe that she did
indeed lose and so I want to check in on
Kerry Lake what's been going on with her
and it's kind of more of the same except
I think as time goes by she gets more
and more delusional as she gets further
away from any reality in which she's
even on a timeline close to when that
election occurred and her delusion just
increases as the time goes by so here's
her actually getting asked if she would
run against Kirsten Cinema for Senate
yikes I don't love thinking about that
um
uh possible reality take a look I know
that polling has been done showing that
I would beat Kirsten Cinema and I've had
I'll be honest I've had many many people
reach out to me and and all kinds of
people reach out to me suggesting that I
run for Senate my focus 100 is on my
election lawsuit the people of Arizona
were done wrong their sacred vote was
trampled upon and I am fighting to
restore honest elections in Arizona I
you know I want to be very obvious here
and I'm speaking something very obvious
DC is messed up it's corrupt Arizona is
corrupt and we need good people in the
senate in our governor's office at the
state level and at the federal level to
fight this corruption so I am focused
right now on winning this election and
getting Katie Hobbs thrown out of the
governor's office so
the fact that she's still saying she's
focused on winning an election that
happened in November and the victor of
that election has already taken office
is wild and it's what we saw with Trump
Jill calling for him to be president him
to be uh you know put into the White
House because of the horrible wrongdoing
and as we'll repeat a million times with
these types of claims you have to have
evidence to make such dangerous
dangerous claims and she doesn't have it
and when she went to court her lost was
thrown out because she didn't provide
the evidence now she's appealing and
appealing but this is the reality and
she just can't accept it and so it's
quite wild to watch I have a few more
moments just to update you on recent
interviews with Carrie Lake kind of uh
a broken record I'll say we will not
accept defeat because we won this race
the people showed
did not put up in massive numbers and
they are so afraid of We the People the
political Elite is so afraid of we the
people that they stole this in broad
daylight they've sabotaged election day
and if we lay down and let them do this
to us now we will never have a country
so we will not
and luckily we got through the Katie
Hobbs
swearing in without any
devastating event brought on by
supporters of Kerry Lake but each time
these claims are perpetuated I get
concerned because we know where these
lies can lead and it really is dangerous
here is another example of her just
making the rounds making the same
dishonest claims if they think they can
steal an election and make this movement
of we the people of Mama bears and Papa
bears who care about their kids of
grandmas and grandpas and students just
go away they've got another thing coming
because we're going to work through the
court system and we will be victorious
we're not letting them
what's interesting is all of those
proclamations we will be Victorious and
we see with individuals like Mike
Lindell always predicting no in two
weeks Trump's going to become president
once again and they never seem to learn
their lesson and by they I mean the
followers of individuals like Kerry Lake
Mike Lindell Trump
who say we're going to be victorious
Carrie Lake's saying I'm definitely
going to end up governor and then when
it keeps not happening why is there no
trust lost
one more thing to show you Republican
Arizona state senator Wendy Rogers I
want to show you how this spreads and
how this is still very much a movement
that's alive that is very concerning
bolstering these claims and pretending
like there's some chance in the world
that Kerry Lake could become governor
um before the end of Katie hobbs's term
Kerry Lake should be our governor she
was elected it was stolen
and her case is on appeal right now it
will meet the appeals court which is a
three judge Court here in a couple of
weeks it will still go beyond that
irrespective of that outcome to the
Arizona Supreme Court where we hope for
a final uh justifiable resolution of
this situation we already have a
resolution Katie Hobbs was one
now she's the governor
um that is the resolution so one of the
things I talk about a lot is when
answering the question of why is it
important to talk about individuals like
Carrie Lake she's not in power neither
is Trump but why should we still discuss
them
the reason is while the Maga ideology
lost I would say in the midterms and the
American people generally were against
it it still is very much prominent
within our current political reality and
holds a lot of people within that uh you
know ideology and so to understand the
movement to address and confront the
movement we have to check in with and uh
look at the lies being told by the
leaders such as Carrie Lake who commands
that movement and it is very dangerous
stuff going on as you saw there if you
like what you're seeing and you're
watching this on YouTube or listening to
the podcast or wherever you are
consuming this content and you want to
check out my show you can go to Luke
Beasley on YouTube there should be a
link in the description if you're
watching on YouTube a quick break we'll
be right back
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show Republican
senator John Kennedy weighed in on the
debt ceiling debacle that's going on
right now negotiations discussions
Republicans wanting to leverage the debt
ceiling to push for spending cuts even
though spending cuts should happen when
you're weighing spending not weighing
fulfilling your financial obligations
all of that has been uh discussed but I
want to take a look at a moment with the
Republican senator John Kennedy
appearing on Fox News and making a point
about
the debt and then we'll respond to it
very fascinating stuff here take a look
if you're going to have a party
you have to pay the band
if you're going to borrow money
you have to pay it back
that's true as a moral principle and a
principle of practicality
and you you don't you don't have to be a
senior at Caltech to figure that out
now here's the truth part
Congress had a spending party
more specifically the house Democrats
not the House Republicans
the Senate Democrats and a whole lot of
Senate Republicans had a spending party
I didn't vote to do it
I would have been happy with a couple of
beers after work
if I don't know how that last sentence
connects to what he was saying honestly
maybe I missed something but let's just
take this as an opportunity to discuss
this myth that Democrats are the
irresponsible Spenders they run up the
debt and the deficit Republicans have to
go in there and clean up the mess and
you hear it all the time and I was
actually hitting
um or sitting I should say at a dinner
last night with a friend talking about
how it's almost impressive the
Republicans despite the facts not being
on their side have convinced so many
people that they are better for the
economy which we know not true and uh
are more financially responsible with
spending they don't run up the deficit
as much and let's just go through a few
pieces I've come across over time that
kind of illustrates this
it is not the case as this New York
Times op-ed rights the Democrats Juiced
the economy by spending money and then
leave Republicans to clean up the mess
over the last four decades in fact
Republican presidents have run up larger
deficits than Democrats another piece
here from towards data science law
Republicans often claim that they are
the more fiscally responsible party my
research suggests otherwise compared to
democratic presidents Republicans are
estimated to add between
0.75 and 1.2 percent more to the deficit
as a percent of GDP each year they are
in office and then we'll look at one
final chart here that shows you the
deficit change whether up or down over
time and of course the reason why we're
speaking in terms of deficit is when
you're looking at fiscal year after
fiscal year
one president would come into power and
we refer to the presidential
um party who's in the white house
because that's the easiest to understand
Congress could be any which way but the
end of the day things have to get signed
off for the most part
um by the president and he kind of holds
authority over his party through that
process and so we can measure it that
way and what we see is actually
Republicans as this chart shows have
jacked up the deficit Democrats have
often decreased it and because Biden's
presidency is only halfway through we
don't have a whole lot of information
to share on that yet but
as I was saying the reason why we talk
in terms of deficit is the debt is just
accumulating it's just on and on and on
and on it gets bigger and bigger and so
saying that this president
was president when the debt was at its
largest is kind of pointless because
even if they got in office and the debt
increased one penny then
they would have the largest debt in
American history that's not really
valuable whereas the deficit is
understanding how much of the budget is
spending Beyond what's being brought in
in taxes right so that's how much each
year is being spent beyond what the
government is actually bringing in in
taxes and that's where you can
understand is a Democrat decreasing that
deficit and bringing down how much more
we're spending or are they increasing
and often Republicans are actually doing
that more are actually increasing the
deficit more contributing than
um
compared to GP and compared to their
time as president more to that scary big
number that the Republican Party likes
to fear-monger a lot about so John
Kennedy there that's just giving you a
historical context because we hear that
talking point so often and if you're in
interpersonal conversations where it
comes up that Republicans are better for
the economy and they're better for
um the debt or whatever it might be we
just understand that's not factual and
even especially with the economy example
as you dive into more and more specific
bits of data you realize how much of a
trend this is that under democratic
presidents even if you control for
Congress and different times based on
crises still Democratic presence are
better for the economy and then we're
looking here
better for the deficit so these branding
items that Republicans have been able to
use so effectively are so often just so
dishonest and so right there John
Kennedy honestly should just think more
about his own party because clearly
historically Democrats aren't the ones
with the problem find me on Twitter Luke
P Beasley Mike Pompeo is making pretty
clear that he wants to run for president
against Donald Trump and it's
interesting to keep an eye on who's kind
of considering a challenge to Trump
within the Republican Party my Pompeo
was the Secretary of State under Donald
Trump here is a moment from Fox News
where he didn't even try to conceal the
fact that yes he's planning on running
process is kind of lay that out people
get a chance to say whoa this this is
huge
um so there is a educational element
that is important as well in the end you
got to pay your bills I am confident
that the United States government will
do so I only worry that we will not
begin to change the trajectory of the
American economy by growing it and the
American and American spending by
reducing it in the meantime you're
running for president aren't you
good throw Neil nice try
um yeah I like that I I like that a
little passive aggressive perfect look
we're doing all the things that one
would do to get to get ready but we're
still trying to figure our way we're
doing all of the things that one would
do to get ready well that's pretty clear
breakthrough we don't have anything to
announce today or would it be impacted
At All by Donald Trump I mean he is
running he's the only announced
candidate uh you know you worked with
him and obviously he has said of Ron
DeSantis of course if he runs it he's to
paraphrase it would be a little disloyal
he's done a lot for them do you feel
that way
oh goodness no
um I was incredibly loyal to America and
to the work that President Trump wanted
done the American people will decide who
the next Republican nominee is and
anybody who throws their hat in the ring
has the responsibility to go out compete
make their case make the arguments to
the people of Iowa New Hampshire and
South Carolina and let the American
people sort through who they think
usually even right before someone
announces they still do the I'm not
thinking about 2024 answer he's going
yeah so we're doing everything to
prepare but I don't have an announcement
right now Okay cool so you're running
and we're waiting on announcement but
what's interesting is Mike Pompeo for a
while now has been making clear that he
wants to run and this whole time I
haven't understood
why he thinks that he's likely to do
well I just don't see him as someone who
could carry a lot of support within the
Republican party because you either have
to be a trumpster which Trump feels
right because he's running or
a really
kind of on the fence trumpster here's
what I mean and it's kind of just a
santis it's the only person who fits
this mold if you're going to do well on
the Republican primary all of these
individuals I wish would not be
president but within this context
DeSantis appeals to the radicals and
appeals more radical than even Trump
sometimes with his vaccine comments
right and also appeals to more moderate
Republicans because he comes off less
erratic like Trump does
um and so he's a little bit more of an
official politician type aesthetic type
Vibe and people are tricked by that and
they think that Ron DeSantis is a more
moderate Republican and would be fine
and so DeSantis feels that Mike Pompeo
is making clear he's not trying to be a
trumpster
but his claim to fame is being Secretary
of State under Trump and he doesn't
really have the
Charisma the political abilities the
past successes in my mind to really
launch him into such a prominent place
in the minds of the Republican base to
defeat Trump or DeSantis just doesn't
seem likely but one of the things I've
been thinking about lately
would it be better for Trump to be up
against a bunch of people Mike Pence
jumps in the race Mike Pompeo jumps in
the race some other mic jumps in the
race
um we saw John Bolton jumping in the
Rays DeSantis and does that do more
damage
even when we know a lot of those people
have no chance of winning or
is it better for it just to be to
Santa's first Trump and them really tear
each other apart
let me know what you think in the
comments
um if you're watching this on YouTube
definitely going to be an interesting
next to years Republican congressman
Byron Donald's appeared on Fox News and
this was a disaster of an interview if
I've ever seen one to the point where
even the Fox News host had to come in
and debunk everything he was saying
about the Biden documents versus Trump
documents case of course now multiple
locations classified documents have been
found at Biden's Properties or by Biden
related properties and that's being
investigated as it should obviously much
less severe than Trump's obstruction and
trying to purposefully keep the
documents from the National Archives and
that's why the rate was necessary and
we'll discuss that further but look at
this moment where it just does not go
well and the fox host can't even save
Byron Donald's from his own humiliation
no problem raiding Mar-A-Lago but let's
go back even before the Mar-A-Lago raid
Donald Trump's attorneys was in
negotiations in talks with the National
Archives they were well aware of what
was happening at Mar-A-Lago so why the
FBI raid you could you you compare that
to what's happened with Joe Biden and
his residents who are yes the FBI was
there but Merrick Garland didn't do his
job at making sure that they were
running the search and investigation to
make sure everything was found and
secured third question did Joe Biden's
attorneys do they have security
clearance to handle these documents and
continue that search that's a major
question as well yeah well but going
back to Mar-A-Lago those negotiations
had gone on for more than a year between
the Department of Justice the Trump uh
organization or not the Trump
organization but the president's
post-presidential organization and the
National Archives and Records
Administration but at some point
president Trump's attorneys told those
entities that all all of the documents
had been handed over when that wasn't
the case which is what prompted The Raid
so in terms of the differences here
there do seem to be some but you believe
that there is still a double standard
here in terms of how those two things
were handled
oh absolutely without a doubt because
here's the other thing you get leaks to
the Press pictures of documents trust
all over the floor so that he just jumps
to a completely different thing okay so
even though both of them stayed calm and
talked professionally that was just so
um I guess the word that she keeps going
to mind is humiliating or embarrassing
because Byron Donald is trying to go
with this new narrative from the right
wing that listen our concerns not about
the classified documents at the end of
the day or I am concerned but that's not
the main concern the real concern is the
double standard we cannot have a
two-tier justice system in the United
States and nothing proves that we have
that more than the fact that Trump was
raided and Biden wasn't
and so we're going to discuss why that's
so absurd but let's kind of step back
for a second and walk through the
timeline
as we built up to this the Trump
Mar-A-Lago situation was going on the
documents there a lot of the right wing
Fox News Republicans were just covering
for Trump defending him
saying this was a Witch Hunt then the
Biden document story breaks before any
of the right wing is able to get a read
on how the left is going to respond how
Democrats are going to respond they
immediately say see nobody cares when
it's spied and everyone cares when it's
Trump
and then
every single Democrat minus a few that
I've seen and as you know in a wholesale
sense I guess the left has been very
much okay with investigations into Biden
and if there's wrongdoing absolutely
hold the proper people accountable based
on the documents we also make clear that
there's a big difference between the
Trump and Biden document situation for
sure it's dishonest to pretend that
there's not but there was no don't talk
about that don't talk about that as they
told us there would be so then I watch
as kind of they had to work up a new
talking point to keep with the double
standard before it was the left's gonna
cover up by it and talk about Trump then
they realized nobody's trying to cover
up and not talk about Biden so now it's
the double standard is Trump was rated
Biden wasn't
but they never go one step further and
try to think about
why that might be do you think raids are
necessary in every single investigation
are raids necessary every single time
documents are in the wrong place no
The Raid was necessary for Trump because
he obstructed time and time again the
national archives from getting the
documents they were requesting and
requesting as the Fox News house had to
come in and say there and Trump
knowingly lied and kept the documents
um which is why they had to eventually
after being incredibly patient raid
Mar-A-Lago
Biden immediately him and his team have
complied have turned over the documents
when they came across them and are fully
on board complying with the
investigation
why would a raid be necessary explain
that to me why would a rape be necessary
genuinely very very strange make sure
you are subscribed to the David packman
show uh YouTube channel and I have a
show of my own of course today I'm
filling in for David while he's away but
if you like what you're saying you go to
Luke Beasley on YouTube link in the
description on YouTube
um and I'll see you after a quick break
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
vaccination rates for children
are continuing to decrease this is not
good this is causing diseases that were
previously not so rampant to get more uh
prominent and that is bad obviously take
a look at this being reported here
hey there everybody U.S childhood
vaccinations have dipped again this year
a new report from the CDC suggests what
started as a concern about the covid-19
vaccine especially in younger people is
now carrying over into other shots too
including polio diphtheria and measles
it's likely one of the reasons cluster
outbreaks of diseases such as measles
are on the rise CDC reports show last
year it was in the Twin Cities Minnesota
area currently it's in and around
Columbus Ohio in the Columbus outbreak
there are over 85 cases and can be
counting that was compared to last
week's data but over 30 of those kids
were hospitalized and most of those
cases were in unvaccinated children Dr
Judy's work is a pediatrician who told
me this new report shows overall those
receiving vaccines required by Most
states is now at about 93 percent it was
at 95 percent just two years ago before
the pandemic hey there everybody so I
know that that decrease may not seem
hugely significant but it is and to see
it starting to be a trend now that we
have a number of years
um out from this initial decline that we
saw is concerning here from Yahoo news
vaccination rates for kindergarten
students are falling
childhood vaccination rates have fallen
for the third year in a row according to
a new report from the Centers for
Disease Control and prevention the
report found that 93 percent of
kindergartners receive state required
vaccines during the 2021-2022 school
year a drop of two percentage points
from the 2019-2020 school year
so
this is obviously concerning just for
health reasons and we are seeing the
effect pretty immediately of this
decrease in vaccinations where we're
seeing outbreaks that are unexpected at
least within the context of the last
number of uh years and decades and these
types diseases if everyone or almost
everyone was getting vaccinated for them
we wouldn't have the issues that we're
having now with in this case children
and so then the question is why and
there's more than just the one that's
coming to all of our brains right now
but obviously the one that we have the
most control over
is the anti-vaxx sentiment that spread
during covet and so it's not to say all
of that percentage is to blame
um not all of that is the fault of
anti-vaxxers but you have to attribute a
good amount to it and that is what we're
getting out of the Public Health
Community that now that so many
individuals are bought into their
political beliefs about the vaccine and
how it's maybe a Bill Gates microchip or
whatever they believe uh they don't feel
safe getting the vaccine so they don't
get their kids vaccinated and it has
negative consequences and so this is
another example of when
misinformation and disinformation have
real world consequences it matters it
matters to have the proper sources
getting you your information about
subjects as important as the health of
your children and unfortunately too many
people in the United States do not have
that whatsoever
I have for you I guess what I would call
a Maga meltdown but it's a Maga Pastor
okay
giving is a Shane Vaughn giving a speech
or a sermon or a remark whatever you
want to call it about Trump and why his
followers his viewers should support
Trump within the context of their
religion
and
what we're seeing here listen this is
not anti-christianity anti-religion at
all this is look at the way he's bending
his religion to support his cult it's
very very concerning
you are the 12 disciples
tired
Donald Trump loses
because he cannot do this without you
and they know that
so that's why every day drama
drama and then here's what Cal would say
I'm tired of all the drama it's not
drama it's spiritual warfare learn the
difference
carnal-minded people think it's drama
when the enemy is attacking and you are
Defending Your territory like Donald
Trump is that's not drama that is
spiritual warfare for the nation of
America it's not pretty it's not fun
it's not clean but somebody's got to do
it call me somebody
Somebody's gotta do it roar 24. I have
made up my mind I'm more determined now
than I've ever been to stand behind this
President I'm more determined now to
stand behind the anointing I don't agree
with everything the man does but I do
agree with everything that God does and
if God's okay with the man I'm ready to
join hands with every one of you I need
some proof that God's okay with Trump
sir and sing like the old black churches
used to saying I'm not tired yet
so let's just set aside that end part
um and try to understand I'm laughing
and it's kind of that you laugh so you
don't cry situation because a lot of
people are bought into this and I know
this anecdotally
um and we understand this in the amount
of people who are hardcore behind Trump
and how that intermingles with their or
intertwines with their faith and so
often when I talk to people about this
it doesn't to me seem like
and again it's your belief system of
course that's completely up to you but
it doesn't seem like you're actually
trying to drive your political beliefs
with uh with something like this uh with
your faith it seems like you really want
to love Trump and so then you're kind of
figuring out how to say well
whatever is going on I know for sure
that God loves Trump so I have to love
Trump
don't exactly explain why God uh has
chosen Trump as the anointed one as he
said there and when I watched that I
just feel like I'm watching a
documentary about a cult about the Trump
cult you know 50 years from now how Wild
was that Trump cult it really is a
historical event at one point he said
you are the 12 disciples that God has
called to stand behind Donald Trump
yikes and so what is so concerning about
this is
in politics
it can get pretty heated and you can
disagree a lot but at the end of the day
if you're able to sit down at a table
lay the facts on the table and then
disagree about Solutions disagree about
minor things Oh I thought this was the
study that best represents the data and
I thought that is all perfectly within a
reasonable political system and still
with people agreeing on basic facts
you'll still
fall very differently on different
political views a hundred percent
what we've gotten to now is individuals
like this Shane Vaughn
make it to where
the ideology is such a circle and it is
such uh you know an impossible situation
to get pulled out of that we can't sit
down and talk about facts I can't even
sit down and try to explain to you why I
think Trump might be against the Bible
because you can Trump that all no pun
intended by saying it doesn't matter I
know for sure that God has anointed
Trump and so it really makes it deeply
impossible
to get somebody out of that cult and
that is what is so concerning about this
and it's why we have to continue to talk
about it and raise awareness and
hopefully
by some of your cool well some people
out of it but I can tell you one thing
it's not going to be sir Pastor Shane
Vaughn
thank you all for watching Today's show
if you enjoyed me hosting go over to
Luke Beasley
on YouTube check out my show the Luke
Beasley show and make sure you're
subscribed there and to the David
packman show here on YouTube we will see
you soon